welcome everybody i want to start today
off and start the week off with
something we really haven't done in
about um in about six weeks which is
just kind of go over what's going on
with kovid because things have changed
pretty dramatically over the last six
weeks
we've not done the weekly covet updates
that at one point we were doing my
thought was
first of all with so much else going on
there's no shortage of things to talk
about but also let's really give this
omicron wave
four to six weeks to burn through and
see where we are once we close in on
mid-february and for the most part in
the united states things are looking so
much better
that there are now
what i would call serious discussions
about moving into the endemic phase
whereas before there was a lot of kind
of hear no evil see no evil let's just
go back to pretending everything is
normal things are not normal now but the
discussions about next steps make a lot
more sense and as i've said before
before we look at the numbers
if there is not
a more deadly
new variant
um
there is sort of nothing else to wait
for before we figure out what will what
will things be like with this as an
endemic thing now endemic doesn't
necessarily mean no risk and to many
people it still means a risk but the
question is sort of if not now when
because if we are moving into an endemic
phase with no
really serious new variant for one year
two years three years
what are we going to do over those one
two or three years if not now what would
be different in two years if the
situation remains sort of as it is now
now one caveat to that is even though
cases are dropping dramatically as i
will soon show you
it's going to take some time for the
hospitals to empty out we are still
seeing
hospitals quite full right now
because of the waves peak now many weeks
ago
and it will take some time for that to
abate assuming there's no new really
contagious and or deadly variant but
let's look at where we are right now if
you look at the united states
daily cases are now down from an insane
peak of 800 000 cases a day
all the way down to 239 000. now that's
still a lot it puts us sort of at the
delta peak but with a variant with
significantly lower rate of
hospitalization rate remember
that's down about
through almost almost three quarters you
look at some individual states you look
at new york new york peaked at seventy
five thousand cases a day and is down to
about eight thousand you know almost a
ninety ninety percent reduction you look
at massachusetts massachusetts peaked at
about twenty four thousand cases a day
down all the way down to 3 000 okay
that's a you know massive massive
reduction even places like texas
seeing a reduction only about 50 percent
but still going
in the downward direction and then when
you look globally globally the decline
is earlier we are earlier in the decline
we had gotten to 3.3 million global
cases a day now down to 2.7 million so
there are parts of the world that are
nowhere near
doing well as we would say
and we will talk about some of those in
a moment but
the important thing for our purposes
is that we are seeing
countries states school districts start
to talk about
what are the next steps now in terms of
vaccinating kids
under five there's the hope i mean i
think that the most optimistic
prediction is by march that may start
it's plausible it's not going to be
march and it could be april maybe or or
maybe even may
but you were starting to see a lot of
places make decisions about travel for
example australia which has been one of
the tightest strictest places since the
start of the pandemic will be reopening
borders to international travel as
reported by the bbc
that's from uh this morning so australia
starting to open there are a number of
additional european countries that are
moving towards what we might call an
exit from the pandemic italy switzerland
and finland are going to be easing
restrictions and guidelines germany and
belgium so far
are not
but many other countries denmark and
others going back to
normal as we might say
still of course with the caveat that
there are going to be people who are
going to continue
doing whatever they've been doing and
one of the interesting things that we've
talked about before is
there's this discussion of when can we
treat this like flu
one answer to make it an empirical
answer and not an emotional answer one
answer would be when the death rate
matches that of flu that that would be
something to look at
it is hypothesized that the omicron
overall death rate is about 0.2 percent
flu is 0.15 so we're not there yet
but it's going in that direction one
additional caveat to that is
the death rate for the vaccinated is
significantly lower than the 0.2 percent
the death rate for the unvaccinated is
significantly higher so
what you can safely
uh
the the framework that you can
accurately assess for yourself does
depend significantly on whether you are
or aren't vaccinated but one of those
questions is well when the death rate
becomes that of the flu
it would make sense to go back to normal
right well no the reality is that these
two years have exposed for a lot of
people i wasn't as safe as i thought
during flu season and there are
absolutely people who
used to not take any precautions
um when flu was rampant during flu
season but even if and when coveted risk
goes back down to match flu it will
still feel more dangerous and that
people will be more aware of that risk
and they may continue to take
precautions and of course everybody
should do exactly what makes sense for
them in conversation with doctors and
based on their their risk assessment but
that's the the conversation that's
happening south korea
as reported by the korea herald pushes
to treat covet 19 like flu
they have lots of cases but low severity
relatively low hospitalizations relative
quite quite a low death rate so that's
the south korean perspective
um in new jersey the governor will be
ending the school mass mandate next
month in march and there are many
municipalities i saw some in uh and by
the way there are places that never did
anything it's like i'm not even talking
or thinking about those i'm talking
about places that did stuff
are now having conversations there's
some municipalities in massachusetts
that are moving away from the masks some
in new york a number of different places
caveat things are still not good in a
lot of places russia has hit a new
record they currently have 10 times more
cases than a month ago to the extent
that we can believe the russian data it
is now 10 times higher cases than a
month ago that's not good for them
um hong kong is bracing for more
uh curbs or or guidelines mandates as
cases are doubling every three days very
complicated situation in hong kong
china is locking down bayes city on the
vietnam border as cases are continuing
to go up still low numbers and of course
china has taken a sort of at least
officially a zero covet approach now
whether that's zero covet or zero
covered reporting you know that there's
debate about that but there are
significant lockdowns happening there as
well so what can we do well i think
again the question is
reminder we've been here before
what is different now
the difference is
there is more support for the discussion
now about moving into the endemic phase
in terms of public opinion than there
ever was before but there's also more
support from medical experts we spoke to
vincent raqueniello two weeks ago
we've read the the opinions of many
other public health experts and
if things change it will require a
different approach but if we are going
in this direction
then there is this question of what are
the milestones we are waiting for and
there are people who are going to keep
themselves in a sort of purgatory for a
very long time that's the reality and
every individual has to balance
you know the the their their risk
tolerance their health situation and the
mental health impact uh that is that is
undeniable uh i mean you know the right
is not wrong when they say there is a
mental health impact of doing this it's
a question of when does the balance
shift
and the answer is different for
everybody
so we're going to continue monitoring
all of these decisions
and seeing
if the downtrend continues which if it
does
within another two weeks we could we
could be 95 to 97 percent down in terms
of daily cases
and when you have that combined with the
effectiveness of vaccines at preventing
death you really have a dramatically
different situation to consider
in terms of what every individual wants
to be doing